that's that's crazy right there that's
crazy so you take a 17 year old kid sir
I know he but hold on he's only 15. when
a fight breaks out after a Massachusetts
literally game a 17 year old boy is
tased after running onto the field
[Applause]
hey man relax relax it happened on June
12th in Worcester Massachusetts about an
hour west of Boston officials there were
called to a baseball park after a fight
broke out between players body camera
video captures officers speaking with
Witnesses who describe what happened
so you're just watching your son play
yeah okay trying to figure out who's the
coach who was who was like a league
president who was just
mind to hang tight everyone else
so you're watching watching the game
whenever it gets over good game uh get
mouthy at the end uh they're doing the
handshake umpires took off I actually
told the umpires being an Umpire I said
hey watch your back they left uh
something happened I'm guessing I'm on
the Schwartz team I'm guessing one of
the kids said something
might have said something from the from
the sports side okay that's what
something happens yeah
at that kid's face and then I kind of
went in and put everybody back in the
Dugout because it was already kind of
split up from The Sword side being like
hey I'll just let it go separate yeah
coach Kelly was dealing with the stuff
on the field that was the guy that just
tried walking up on us I just kind of
got in the middle uh
all the kids started coming so again me
and the other coach kind of made contact
I pointed that way like take your kids
out that way I'll keep my kids in here
not even my kids the Schwarz kids get
the hell out of here and we'll stay in
the field if you go around we run around
there's some back and forth two or three
through the fence like they came out the
Third Base Line they were going out so
by the by the trees right like get out
of there so coming up behind that blue
building yep yeah yeah that's what I
mean yeah yeah
so there's a little bit of a
up story
first of all in one in our intermediate
game this year between garrig and
Schwartz which is I'm looking at is also
yeah during the intermediate thing about
a month or so ago between Gary and
Schwartz the police had to come some of
the players and the parents would get
were threatening to shoot one of the
umpires
they had to cancel that game and that
that Garrick team sold it
um
a few of their players had an issue with
one of my players in Fall baseball from
this fight
so the last time we played them still
threatening my son he's telling what
goes around coming around okay so
where's your car
over there
that's your white car sir
all right let's get it let's get you
into your car to get you out of here hey
Manny can we just keep our mouth I'm not
saying anything people are telling me
can you just step in your car I'm good
I'm good I just don't I no I just don't
want anymore okay there's this guy video
shows some adults involved in the brawl
receiving medical attention
listen I know you were saying you didn't
want it but like you kept on peeling
over and get checked out
as soon as I got hit I tried to scramble
up and eventually the crowds dispersed
and some people appear to make amends
sorry about that I'm sorry I thought I
thought you didn't want him seeing
anything no no no no no no no no I don't
want anymore it was an excellent game
and I understand that from playing
sports things get heated but we can't
have it heated where the cops are coming
this gotta end like we gotta people need
to go home about 15 minutes into the
body camera recordings the parents of a
15 year old boy who was hit arrive on
the scene as officers explain what's
going on the boy's 17 year old brother
runs out onto the field that's when
another brawl breaks out because the boy
is 17 years old most of the video is
blurred oh Jim I understand there's a
back history and all that what happened
today on today we were the game ended it
was a close game that's what I've been
doing several times we're walking
through the line and the kid who had
started with our pictures before kind of
like shouldered him and I didn't I don't
know if anything was said but he should
the next thing you know as arcade walk
by like
help suddenly stop promotion any like
through a glove Adam who did this horse
to a Lou Gehrig or Lou Gehrig just works
[Applause]
hey man relax relax
body camera video shows these same
moments from another angle what's the
problem there's no problems
oh my God
seconds later an officer tases the 17
year old boy
no no
hey
sir sir
almost immediately the boy's father
begins yelling at police demanding
answers
ma'am
come here
over here
explain to you let me explain to you
let me explain to you
that's that's crazy right there that's
crazy so enjoyed a 17 year old kid sir I
know he is hold on he's only 15. I
understand that sir
that's my son
he has to be here
everyone's gonna go to court now
regarding this video from another
officer shows the boy's mother reacting
calling for the officers to tase her
instead
[Laughter]
take me
thank you
the 17 year old then apologizes to the
officer who tased him twice I'm sorry
for my actions
and I know my mom
now I'm sorry
I'm sorry I just blacked out somebody
hit my brother I understand I know you
don't want him
meanwhile the boy's parents continue to
speak with First Responders arguing the
boy never should have been tased in the
first place
I need to know what is the under arrest
[Music]
okay for what you guys got it it's
initially as an emergency call because
of your son right yeah we were trying to
handle that all right and I understand
the emotions were high because you were
like what did my son get involved
he's never been in trouble
it should be an even thing the guy hit
my thumb and left you took a Lego with
my kid right now too that's why that's
what you happen okay we are in the
middle of handling the whole situation
Carlos I understand
I went after him
as we do too he's charging at some
people probably assuming
and he had mental problems and I'm
hisparent well he was running I was
running after him trying to
in the end the 17 year old was charged
with assault and battery so far his name
hasn't been released publicly two adults
were also charged in relation to the
incident but their names haven't been
released either reporting for lone crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie law and
crime network is searching the country
for the best detective in the United
States we're looking for the top
investigators who helped to solve the
nation's most high profile cases from
medical examiners to forensic experts or
even private eyes if you or someone you
know believes they're one of America's
greatest detectives submit your
applications now the top three
detectives will be featured on our
social media and the winner give in a
five thousand dollar prize go to
lawncrime.com detective to submit your
nomination